drums and flags from across the
continent European workers have gathered
in Brussels to demonstrate for more
social protection this is a
demonstration for Europe and social
protection there's a summit in göteborg
and we want all heads of government to
put the basic rights for all workers
into law
Europe has traditionally distinguished
itself from the US Asia or Latin America
in its social tendencies high taxes
strong social safety nets and tightly
regulated labor markets now the European
Commission wants enshrined these values
in what Commission President Juncker has
coined the European pillar of social
rights the visual instrument at the very
least we should agree on a European
Union of social standards Europe cannot
work the chance its workers a central
part of the initiative is this so-called
work-life balance proposal it would
allow new fathers to take more time off
and encourage women to enter and stay in
the workforce brussels hopes that the
initiative will restore faith in the
european project you know we are
spending more than 50% of the social
expenditures in the world and that's
basically the resin d'etre of the
european union that's what we want we
want wealth to be distributed and to be
flowing to everyone and not just to the
happy few and yes I do believe that this
is the critical instrument to make do
you loft again by the people today there
are significant differences between
member states when it comes to social
protection according to the Battlement
social justice index access to the labor
market education and health services
vary widely across the EU as does the
risk of poverty I would argue it's
actually the main risk of this
declaration of social rights is actually
that something is being declared and you
know basically nothing of this can can
be enforced in courts and you know it
raises big expectations among some
people and you know it will achieve
perhaps much less than than that from
the outset the European project has been
dominated by economic into
raishin that social dimension was a mere
by-product that you will now make an
ambitious political commitment and
göteborg aiming towards the more social
Europe